is it true that you resigned from
jackiebrown to do West Beirut I would I
had I think we had 50 days on Jackie
Brown and I had two days left and when
the producer called from Paris and he
said look we got the fund I could not
wait but to go immediately so I went to
Quentin and I said the Quentin look I've
been you know I gotta go do my movie
he says you still have two days left I
said I really gotta go he says go so I
went and and then I had to leave just
couple of days before Wow
some of the things that I found very
interesting watching it again now and my
first time watching it on the big screen
was you have such sense sensuality as a
filmmaker like that I found in all three
of your films West Beirut Lila says and
the attack that sex is a part of your
filmmaking it's a it's a theme in there
that you see and sensuality and how you
also complement that with the camera can
you talk a little bit about that because
like for example some things that like
you know I grew up in the Middle East
and in Kuwait and some of the things
that we see in the film are a little bit
taboo just talking about sex or just you
know these boys peeking and you know
staring it at this this woman's boobs
and talking about a rock it was true
though it was like that but can you can
you talk can you talk about like because
I've seen that throughout your films and
and I've I'm just curious like how are
you informed by that as a filmmaker its
genetic I think it's problem
look uh it is I lived surrounded by a
very very powerful figure in my life
it's my mom my mom had a lot of
influence in me and she still has an
incredible presence in my life she's 76
years old now and she is a lawyer and
she's still working lawyer and my mom
being an Arab woman had always fought
until today for women's right she's
still fighting for making introducing
the civil marriage in Lebanon Lebanon
does Knife civil marriage it only has
religious marriage she fight against the
female circumcision she wrote a book
about it
and she's still very very active I don't
want to make it a philosophical and say
because of my mom I you you know writing
process is much more organic than that I
can't pin it down to one and one reason
only but I know that I grew up in a very
liberal family my mom was very liberal
she was very militant extremists in
certain ways radical my mom is not a
moderator like my dad is but she left an
everlasting impression about expressing
yourself including sexuality even though
she comes from a very conservative Sunni
Muslim family she rebelled against the
clerical thinking and I kind of like
always saw her as somebody who left
early a very big influence but the
reason I always talk about the womanhood
and the woman ship and the sexuality in
my film is because I don't know maybe
because I was brought up a little way
maybe because there was a lot of women
in my family you know like my aunts and
my cousins I really can't tell it but
wait to see the next film the guy who
plays Tareq the main character is
actually my brother but and the reason I
casted him is because I could not find
you see in America if you go to a
casting director you go to an agent and
there is an incredible big range of
choices that you have a parents if they
encourage their kids to go into acting
and they pursue it and that's that's how
it is in Lebanon you don't have that
most of the parents are very afraid to
let their kids are at high school it's
so sacred to finish high school it's so
like it's their main worry my parents
were more worried about me not finishing
high school learn about the war really
this is something like an incredible
pressure so when I went to Beirut and
started looking for casting I could not
find a single family that would agree to
let their kids 14 13 years old 15 years
old out of high school and then finally
I said damn I have my brother my brother
it's really that age and I gave it to
him one time he came to America just
before I start filming and I was driving
with my dad and my my brother Rami up to
Yosemite my dad had never seen it and I
remember so well I'm driving the car my
dad sitting next to me and my brother
Ram is sitting in the backseat and I'm
looking in a reviewer mirror and he was
laughing and I knew what it scenes he
was laughing
and then I came back to Beirut when we
started prepping I started looking for
so many other casting just to make sure
that I'm not being nepeta stunts to hire
your brother just because you know you
want to go through a filtration system
but my mind was stuck on him I thought
he really knew the role I felt it how
was it directing him it was very easy he
was just so comfortable with this
personality with the role of Tariq what
was difficult is the other guy
this small kid because because of the
the limits that I had casting from
regular family finally my mom suggested
she says you know what we don't mind to
have Tariq around me my brother leaves
school but how are you gonna catch the
other kid I said I don't know mom I've
been casting for looking for three four
months I couldn't fight she says I got
an idea for you go to an orphanage
that's why I went to an orphanage and I
started looking and it was a Muslim
conservative orphanage and I found him
right away and I felt like that guy he
has a look I gotta have him only he
turned out to be a huge crook he was a
thief
and because he had to survive that way
well he was so poor in fact when I
started filming he was living in a
refugee camp the Palestinian refugee
camp even though his Lebanese extremely
poor I told the producers we can I can't
be filming while he's there how about I
ran an apartment and I'll have an extra
room where I'll give it to him so he can
stay close I could keep watch on him
keep my eyes on him and one time I wake
up in the morning and I find out that my
vitamin pills was gone then the next day
the toothpaste is gone every day
something was being gone then I said
could it be this guy
I took I talked to my mom about it she
says look you know it's possible so I I
put a I remember I put a $10 bill on a
counter and I waited next day it was
gone and we ended up paying him his per
team that way every day would leave him
$20 so he was just very he was very
blunt about it and I did never ask him
you know Mohammed his name is the sad
thing is during the shooting toward the
end he discovered that he had a father
and he knew actually he had a father but
he never talked about it the reason he
did not mention about his father is to
attract sympathy because naturally a
human being one and help our orphans so
he kept his father's idea father's think
completely secret until the money came
we had to pay him salary and then my mom
asked him she says you know it's we
can't pay you here 16 years old he says
well I have a father and we had to work
out a way to pay him for his father and
then we find out later that all the
money he was paid his father took it
because he was a heroin addict so it was
all you know it's always very very
complicated but but you know this guy is
he was very savvy he was a real street
kid and he and my brother fell in love
with that girl in the film which caused
the real problems this is when the
problem started because you know and and
I remember taking rola the girl aside I
said look rola I know that my brother's
in love with you and the other guy
Muhammad is in love with you what are
you gonna do she says I don't care I
don't love
none of them so Wow yeah